i'm so confident now um
the haters spotted looks like lonely boy
finally hooked up with the big one and
our big little spies say aaron isn't too
happy is someone watching me seems as if
captain rogers is saluting his commander
no shut up with the anonymous fake news
i swear to god swearing to god maybe
this sinner wants to be a saint
i can't either confirmed or dead x's and
o's x's and o's secret scoopster ah the
post season the time of year when teams
hope they can hack it and try to avoid
giant mistakes i'm the new joe judge let
me tell you parasites what's up hey he's
mean just like a city yeah
i'm here for my interview brian's
complaints have no merit hashtag and
racism spotted mr unlimited testing his
limits dude your ex got hot it was
mutual these rumors have gotten out of
hand troubling glendale deleted tweets
show kyler's not so sweet smear just
called the social media club's fam
pastor jack easterby is calling the
shots in houston you know we should all
draft at defensive end jesus christ and
new vikings coach willing to work with
cousins okay but that last one sounded
reasonable tonight at brady's farewell
party we unmasked secret scoopster
drop the confetti the game isn't over
yet yeah but i just saved was state farm
[Music]
welcome remember to dress up as your
favorite brady but they're all great so
we flirt with teams and see what gets
leaked hey john elway don't you dare
broncos are my team to lead on sorry i'm
let jacked aren't you a tall glass of
water i can't believe it makes sense to
stay say do you want to go back to my
place sure but heads up i barely
performed oh don't mind me i'm just
waving my no trade claws you're moving
wilson we're just going to stop for a
year no posts despite all the drama i'm
sorry derek i just can't commit to you
coach mcdaniels no he just uses us
thank you all for coming i've had so
many wonderful years here with tampa
spotted dangerous looking scandal rust
in nyc aha of course i don't want to go
to the giants but now we know the
scoopster is in the room i'm too wrong
to be secret scoopster
and i'm too slow new alert no qb's in
the giraffe looks like it's long snapper
season baby bb
oh my god i'm so embarrassed i thought i
was texting my son
[Music]
well goodbye thanks for the memories
okay that's a series wrap on the nfl
congrats everyone on a great run oh we
were gonna maybe continue playing
football what what's the point i was the
main character and i did it all well
there's some exciting new characters no
nope cut print it's over thanks for
watching tom brady's gridiron heights